-Finally everybody,
it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WePost."
Here we go.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪ WePost ♪
-Welcome to "WePost."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is where we
as a group decide something
that we should post on socials.
I'm going to show you
five different posts,
and we're all going to vote
on whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
There's green for yes,
red for no.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want. We're going
to see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have your clickers too?
-Ready?
-Yep. Tariq, are you
in a positive mood this evening?
-I mean, it depends.
Like, once you start reading
them posts, then we'll see.
-Yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Tonight I will post whichever
one gets the most likes
from all of us
because it's not a MePost.
No, no, no, it is a WePost.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Alright. Ready?
The first post is...
[ Light laughter ]
I'll just do --
Eh, I'll go -- I'll lift it up.
Let me go all the way
underneath.
Alright, here we go.
I think this one's going to be
a little bit better, though,
I don't know.
Let me see this one.
Alright. Hey, that's not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go.
-I don't know
if we're in posting levels yet,
but that one's better than --
-That one's better than
the last one.
-Yeah.
-Twice as much.
-Tariq is just not
speaking at all.
He's just lost.
-I mean, here's the thing.
Respectfully,
I haven't cared for one yet.
[ Laughter ]
-When you said respectfully
and then insulted me,
what -- did you want me to --
-I wanted to take the edge off.
[ Laughter ]
-It worked. It worked.
I kind of thought
that was respectful. Thanks.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
A little dippity doo.
-[ Squelching ]
-Alright, let's see
the results here.
Hair in the '90s?
Hey, not bad!
Now we're talking!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now we're talking.
Now I'm seeing something.
Tariq's got a little --
He's got a little smile.
-Been like a ladder.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-This one's a little better.
-Yeah, I think this next one
might be the one.
-Really?
-Yeah. I have a feeling.
I could see it right now
on the cue cards,
and I think this might be it.
-Let's do it.
-Alright. Here we go.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
Just kind of sticks in there.
Just kind of stays in there
and you go, "Oh, yeah."
-Just love it.
-There you go.
That's my -- Out
of all the molasses candies,
all the molasses
chewable candies,
Bit-O-Honey is up there.
-It's definitely up there.
-Let's see the results here.
-Ooh!
-Wow.
-Alright, might be
the other one,
but I think it's going
to be this one.
-They said, "Thank you, no."
-This one,
I'm not only -- I'm saying
it's going to be this one,
but this one might even
get a standing ovation.
-Really? It's that good?
-I don't know if it's that good.
I just feel like the audience
wants to stand up.
-Yeah. Seventh inning stretch.
-Maybe we could see --
It's made me laugh.
This made me laugh.
-This one made you laugh.
-It made me laugh in rehearsal.
And yeah.
-Okay.
-So I think this is the one.
If I could take
all my votes back
and add it all to this,
I would do it.
I'm going to press it now
just in case.
-Oh, my gosh.
It's called the prequel.
-I don't know
if it even works right now.
-Yeah.
-But I'm going to do that
just in case they turn
the computers on now.
Alright. The last one says...
[ Laughter ]
Not bad, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-I feel good about this.
-Standing ovation.
-If we win, do we get
a standing ovation?
Let's see the results.
Booyah! Come on, get up!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
Guys, you nailed it.
Looks like the winner
is mannequin right there.
I'm going to post this
during the break.
If you happen to see it online,
give that WePost a repost.
We have a great show.